our next speaker is uh galena livesheitz
uh she's an assistant professor at the
georgia institute of technology
and currently a research fellow in the
probability program galena will be using
this bible board to give us
talk thank you very much so let me
actually put the scribble board
in the chat in fact i think that my
connection is not working so well i'm
very happy that i'm
i've opted to that scribble board option
i'll be scrolling it
um so you can follow us as a link to the
chat to
follow the slides this very short
presentation
i'll talk about the smaller singular
value of the homogeneous and the
matrices
um so imagine that somebody asks you the
following question
pick a large integer perhaps a million
and say somebody gives you a fair die
and asks you to flip it and square times
so a million square times
you get a bunch of outcomes from one to
six
and you can fill um n by n matrix with
this outcomes
so it's a random matrix of size n by n
question how likely is this matrix to be
invertible
uh next imagine somebody asks you a
slightly
more difficult question instead of one
third eye suppose you have a whole bunch
of
maybe million square different dice and
some of them may be cubic some of them
octagonal some some simplicial
and instead of rolling the same die
every time you need to fill an entry of
this matrix you're all a different die
and fill your matrix with outcomes and
again the question is
how likely is this matrix to be
invertible
so uh surprisingly so while the first
question has been done quite a lot the
second question
has not been studied that much um
in my recent work with american
machining we showed that
under very general assumptions
one can prove the optimal
essential optimal uh estimate on the
smallest singular value offer and the
matrix with these different entries so
imagine a hovering the matrix with
independent entries
uh on average the gilbert schmidt norm
of this matrix is bounded by
something of order and squared and
suppose also there is an auxiliary
assumption that
the entries are uniformly
anti-concentrated meaning that
basically they are not all equal to the
same
number with high probability they are
truly random
so i assume that yeah they are truly
random roughly speaking uniformly
then the smaller singular value is very
high overwhelming high probability is
bigger than
something over square root of n where
again n is the size of the
matrix and this property this behavior
is
optimal in a way um
let me also mention another result uh
of earlier result of mine um
by the way sorry i need to probably say
a few words about history so
there there's been a huge history in
this regard with important results
obtained
by uh sherbet spielmann and deng and
brotherson and virginian and tao and wu
and we brought into hamirov
and uh um litwak and
tonja kyageman and uh many many others
um and pretty much with the same set of
names
um many many things were known also
before about
this question so suppose instead of
considering a square matrix we consider
a rectangular matrix
uh obvious again independently uniformly
concentrated entries
uh i needed the assumption of id rows
mean zero variance one
then again we have a completely tight
behavior small ball behavior of the
smallest singular
value of this rectangular matrix so this
question is for a matrix that looks like
this maybe n is bigger than but
we permit absolutely arbitrary and as
long as n is bigger than or equal to
little n in some cases i guess i'm soon
going to build out of them
in some cases one can improve um this
estimates for instance if your matrix is
uh very tall and you know your capital n
is much much larger than little n
then you need to assume much weaker you
need to place a much weaker assumption
on
the entries of the matrix to still have
the sharp result
and furthermore if you don't care about
a very sharp probability estimate
you don't need to assume independent
entries you only need to assume
independent rows
and some anti-concentration property on
the rows and then you still
and you have the result